la medida de dos ángulos de un triángulo
isósceles son 3 x 5 grados y x + 16
grados hallar todos los posibles valores
de x muy bien vamos a pensar en esto
vamos a dibujar nosotros mismos un
triángulo isósceles o más bien vamos a
dibujar varios eso es un triángulo
isósceles y vamos a hacer una copia de
ese triángulo de este lado para ver
todas las posibilidades que tenemos muy
bien entonces qué es lo que sabemos que
un triángulo isósceles tiene sus ángulos
de la base iguales muy bien entonces qué
posibilidades tenemos tenemos que los
ángulos son 3 x + 5 y x + 16 bueno el
primer caso es que 3 x 5 o sea uno de
estos ángulos y que el ángulo que esté
en el vértice superior sea x + 16 ok
así tenemos ya esos dos ángulos en este
caso van a ser iguales es decir que 3 x
5 y x 16 sean los ángulos que se
encuentran en la base y finalmente bueno
tenemos tenemos otra posibilidad verdad
que intercambiemos el valor de 3 x 5 y x
+ 16 del primer triángulo vamos a hacer
otro otro dibujo para que para que sea
claro claramente en el segundo no tiene
caso invertirlo porque son lo mismo
entonces vamos a suponer en el tercer
caso que el ángulo que está en la base
mide x + 16 y el ángulo que está en el
vértice superior es el que mide 3 x + 5
así que vamos a empezar el trabajo con
cada uno de ellos en este caso si los
ángulos de la base miden 3 x 5 entonces
vamos a sumar todos los ángulos y
sabemos que nos debe dar 180 es decir 3
x + 5 + 3 x + 5 + x 16 eso nos debe dar
180 grados muy bien ahora agrupamos
vamos a ver aquí tenemos un 3 x + 3 x
que son 6 x y x tenemos 7 x ahora bien
tenemos 5 + 5 que son 10 y más 16 que
son 26 ok y eso es igual a 180 ahora si
restamos 26 de ambos lados de la
igualdad que tendremos bueno tendremos 7
x va a ser igual a 180 menos 26 180
menos 20 son 160 y si le restamos 6 son
muy bien entonces tenemos que 7x sera
y ahora si dividimos entre 7 por ambos
lados de la igualdad
tendremos que 154 entre 7 a que nos da
bueno x va a ser 22 y si es 22 bueno
veamos 7 por 20 son 140 más 2 por 7 que
son 14 son 140 más 14 son 154 en efecto
entonces x vale en este escenario 22
ahora pensemos en este siguiente caso
ahora tenemos que estos dos ángulos van
a ser iguales es decir 3 x más 5 es
igual a x 16 bueno restamos x de ambos
lados de la igualdad y esto nos queda
del lado izquierdo 2 x + 5 igual a 16
restamos ahora 5 de ambos lados y nos
queda 2x igual a 11
ahora dividimos entre 2 y nos queda que
x será igual a 11 medios
muy bien y este es nuestro segundo
escenario x vale 11 medios vámonos con
el tercero en este caso la base o los
ángulos de la base miden x 16 ok y estos
son iguales vamos a hacer lo mismo que
en el primer caso sumamos estos 3 y
garantizamos que la suma son 180 es
decir x 16 más x + 16 13 x + 5 cuando
sumamos todo eso nos debe dar 180 grados
muy bien ahora agrupamos todo lo que
tiene x aquí tenemos 1 2 y otras 3
tenemos 5x muy bien tenemos 5x y ahora
agrupamos 16 con 16 que son 32 y si le
sumamos 5 nos da 37 y eso nos debe dar
180 grados ok restamos ahora 37 de ambos
lados de la igualdad y nos queda 5x
igual a 180 menos 37 y 180 menos 30 son
150 y si restamos 7 son 143 dividamos
entre 5 y nos queda finalmente que x son
143 entre 5 que lo dejamos como fracción
podríamos escribirlo como número mixto
pero con esto es suficiente ok
estos son los tres posibles valores de x
con la información que nos dieron